[Applause]
under 40 seconds of playing this first
half
Duggan
throwing complete
that's Quinton Johnston their go-to
receiver you pick it up you'll go a
little quicker here see that soft spot
in the middle of the Zone good
protection by the offensive line for two
from 99 yards away in the plains of the
Midwest now in the middle got some of it
and Johnson wants a lot of it Johnston
in open space dragging Kansas across the
Jayhawk logo
I think they wanted to get Quentin
Johnson involved today and that is a the
softest cushion we have seen oh I've got
to keep it in front of you but that was
just way too easy of a pitch and catch
and there's your Bruce Feldman's
freakless
pressure again from Phelps quick release
by Duggan it's Johnston again tight
roping and a jacket cut inside the 20. I
didn't get the 99 the first time but
once again cushion space but the
difference are the two missed tackles
afterwards they didn't make TCU earn it
time and time again but on this
possession they're not two back-to-back
explosive plays and you can't duck your
head if you're mellow Dotson or you're
going to be reaching for air or he went
High last time
touchdown
[Applause]
that foot was down that first foot was
down when his massive hits the armed
arms hands are wrapped around the ball
missed not pits mitts are wrapped around
the ball I can't even speak with the
play making going on right now I mean
this is this is ludicrous
time it again these athletic Dynamic
electric receivers are just
I mean that's through contact he's
getting interfered with he catches the
ball at the very last moment the defense
has three seconds to begin their
substitution but they need to be quick
about it they don't have to Sprint but
they do need to do it Expeditions yeah
and they weren't really expeditious
there's a team
[Applause]
at the one-yard line by Quentin Johnson
it's the height and his ability to go up
and catch it at the top of the jump
because there's a safety Oklahoma state
has really stifled This Crowd
third down and three
Duggan fires Clinton Johnston in the
open field that is his patented move
Sean I mean he does it all the time says
he catches it and almost like a post
player in basketball little head fake
and pivot and he leaves the defender
behind jabal
pressure coming
and he throws it it's a spin move
Johnston that spin move sheds another he
can fly and they knocked him out of
bounds my goodness is he Dynamic knowing
pressure's coming so one-on-one and
here's the spin move head fake inside
spin outside and then strength to break
the tackle Mason Cobbs
after the fake Duggan has a man open
it's Johnston for the touchdown
[Music]
let's watch this guy right here his eyes
are on the ball fake and you're going to
see a receiver run right by him in the
form of Quentin Johnston it opened up
the seam the Run fate pulled the
Oklahoma State Defense and why wouldn't
you go to this guy had the game-winning
touchdown a week ago against
at least they came out that cover two
show now they can defend the one looking
for Johnston now speaking of big plays
he's got and it's a touchdown
[Applause]
thank you
Jimmy squat dog read is what we call it
when you're able to put a guy in your
pocket and he stumbles
right hamstring to Julius Prince there
the left cornerback but he went past him
like hit him like he stole something
play action Duggan again all kinds of
Todd floats one and drops it into
Johnston he's gone touchdown
from the medical tent to the end zone
for Quinton Johnston
[Applause]
Johnston's just going to run the Deep
Over route and he's going to get matched
up right here with number 13. Hershey
McLaren there's going to be a little bit
of contact with Johnston fights through
it McLaurin hits the ground and then
there's absolutely nobody after that a
nice little Shield block down the field
by Darius Davis
this time Duncan has time he delivers
that dark down the field and it's caught
by Johnston and he's still running and
the big player receiver makes the first
big play of the night first down at the
11. by the offensive line they're
playing Zone Johnston who's known to go
downfield this time settles in perfectly
look at the poison to calm demeanor
there on Third and long with an offense
it's not been clicking makes a perfect
Texas brings pressure Duggan back pedals
lost to the end zone wide open Johnson
touchdown
a confused Texas secondary left the
elite receiver wide open 31-yard strike
watch the safety in the back end they're
disguising pressure here then that ends
up dropping now watch the safety in the
back end right here is the confusion go
to the Post the safety doesn't go with
him had no idea that Johnston snuck it
thank you
Duggan down the field middle of the
field right on target for Johnston
and it's what they do and what this guy
does as well as anybody in the country
at six foot four he closes the cushion
of the senior Milton gets right on his
toes and Duggan his favorite ball is
that one the Deep shots
second in the country 56 six percent
when he Chucks it over
thank you
Wildcats crowding the line Duggan back
takes a downfield shot in the second
play and it's done with it over the
shoulder catch Ben Johnston beat Julius
Branch just like in the first meeting in
Fort Worth got a safety in the middle of
the field creates a one-on-one
opportunity on the outside linebackers
are coming down against a Potential
Threat for the Run get pressure on the
quarterback and how about this for your
first throw of the game and a map he's
trying to coach him home play pick on
first down Duggan wanted a downfield
shot will launch for Johnston he's wide
open Brenton Johnson collects it and is
tackled at the 29 by Josh Hayes just in
a couple of big plays to go along with
the fumble in the first half and off to
the right is that matchup 6-4 against
6-4 and but this time Julius Brands
really for the first time we've seen him
out